This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in the 1960s and 70s in the city of Pittsburgh, there was a nickname for guys like John Moon, the unemployed. We simply meant that no matter where you went for a job, nobody would hire you. Moon grew up in Pittsburgh's largely black and economically depressed hill district. In better times, the hill had its own neuro-league baseball team, and jazz clubs that hosted Duke Hellington and Louis Armstrong. But by the time Moon was graduating high school in the late 1960s, there was no escaping the neighborhoods, unemployable stigma.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在20世纪60年代和70年代的匹兹堡市，像约翰·穆恩这样失业的人有一个绰号。我们的意思很简单，无论你去哪里找工作，都没人会雇佣你。穆恩在匹兹堡黑人聚居且经济萧条的希尔区长大。在更好的时期，希尔区有自己的黑人联盟棒球队，还有接待过艾灵顿公爵和路易斯·阿姆斯特朗的爵士俱乐部。但到了20世纪60年代末穆恩高中毕业时，他已经无法摆脱社区那种“不可雇佣”的污名了。
The reputation was there, but I don't want to go to the hill because you may get beat up. You have drug addicts and alcoholics, and that same label was placed on myself, and I understood that. But just because that was your thought doesn't necessarily mean that I had to live up to it. So Moon was glad to land a well-paying job right at a school at the local steel mill, only to discover that the hours weren't as reliable as he had hoped. Next, he was in orderly at Pittsburgh's Presbyterian University Hospital, which provided steady employment, but not much else.
名声就在那里，但我不想去希尔区，因为你可能会挨揍。那里有吸毒者和酗酒者，同样的标签也贴在了我身上，我明白这一点。但仅仅因为那是你们的想法，并不意味着我必须活成那样。所以穆恩很高兴能在当地一家钢铁厂的学校找到一份高薪工作，却发现工作时间并不像他希望的那样稳定。接下来，他在匹兹堡长老会大学医院当了一名护工，这份工作提供了稳定的收入，但除此之外别无他物。
All I was doing was making beds and taking people back and forth to the operating room and lifting and stuff like that, mechanical things where you didn't have to think. For a while, Moon tried his best to find meaning in the work. But there was a part of me that said there has to be something more that I can do. Then one night, halfway through the graveyard shift, Moon watched as two men burst through the doors of the hospital. They were working desperately to save a dying patient. And as they rushed by, Moon stood
我所做的只是铺床、把病人送往手术室、搬运东西之类的体力活，这些机械性的工作根本不需要动脑子。有一段时间，穆恩尽力在工作中寻找意义。但我内心深处有一个声音说，我一定能做更多的事情。一天晚上，在夜班进行到一半时，穆恩看到两个男人冲进了医院大门。他们正在拼命抢救一名垂死的病人。当他们匆匆跑过时，穆恩站在
pressed against the wall and wondered, who are these people? What are they doing? How do they get to be able to do that? Maybe today he wouldn't bet an eye at this scene, but in 1970 nothing about it made sense. The two men weren't doctors and they weren't nurses, and their strange white uniforms weren't hospital issue. But these guys came in with a certain type of confidence that was just shocking to me from the very point that they came into the room. And they had an emblem on their breasts that just picked my interests.
紧贴着墙壁，心想，这些人是谁？他们在做什么？他们是怎么做到这些的？也许今天他不会对这一幕多看一眼，但在1970年，这一切都令人费解。这两个人不是医生，也不是护士，他们奇怪的白色制服也不是医院发的。但这些人走进房间时带着一种自信，从他们进门的那一刻起就让我感到震惊。他们的胸前有一个徽章，引起了我的兴趣。
The emblem was the two snake to caduceus, the traditional sign of medicine and healing. But just below the familiar symbol was a word John Moon had never seen before, paramedic. Moon wasn't familiar with the term paramedic, because back then, no one was. That's reporter Kevin Hazard. Moon was witnessing a birth of a new profession, one that would go on to change the face of emergency medicine. But to Moon, perhaps the most striking thing of all, was that these first ever paramedics looked like him.
那个徽章是双蛇杖，是医学和治愈的传统标志。但在那个熟悉的符号下方，有一个约翰·穆恩从未见过的词：护理人员（paramedic）。穆恩对“护理人员”这个词并不熟悉，因为当时没人知道。那是记者凯文·哈扎德。穆恩正在见证一个新职业的诞生，这个职业将改变急救医学的面貌。但对穆恩来说，也许最令人震惊的是，这些第一批护理人员长得和他一样。
I'm standing here looking at these two guys and I'm saying to myself, my God, these are black guys. Never before had moonsing young African-American men performing that kind of work. These were two guys that had afros in Beards and the staff on the floor gave them a level of respect that amazed me. And there's something I never really mentioned to anyone. I actually snuck off of the floor, and I actually followed them out to the vehicle. Because I wanted to see what prompted them to show such proudness and boldness. Once I looked at that vehicle, pull off,
我站在那里看着这两个人，心想，天哪，他们是黑人。我从未见过年轻的非裔美国人从事那种工作。这两个人留着爆炸头和胡子，楼层里的工作人员对他们表现出的尊重让我感到惊讶。还有一件事我从未向任何人提起过。我实际上溜出了楼层，跟着他们到了车边。因为我想看看是什么让他们表现出那种自豪和果敢。当我看着那辆车开走时，
it was almost like, there goes my job. There goes my career. That's what I wanna do. Moonbelt right then halfway through his long night shift to become a paramedic. Whatever that was. And in Pittsburgh in 1970, the only place to do that was an organization called Freedom
感觉就像是，我的工作机会在那儿。我的职业生涯在那儿。那才是我想要做的。穆恩在那漫长夜班的中途就下定决心要成为一名护理人员。不管那是什么。而在1970年的匹兹堡，唯一能做到这一点的地方是一个叫“自由之家”的组织。
House Ambient Service. So I went and applied to get a job with him and the rest is history. But that history about how a group of young black men from Pittsburgh became the world's first paramedics is still largely unknown. I'm a former paramedic myself. I did this job for ten years, and you'd think the profession's origin story would be a big deal. But the truth is, most of the EMTs I've talked to have never heard of the Freedom House paramedics,
“自由之家救护服务”。所以我去申请了那里的工作，剩下的就是历史了。但关于一群来自匹兹堡的年轻黑人如何成为世界上第一批护理人员的历史，至今仍鲜为人知。我自己也曾是一名护理人员。我做了十年这份工作，你可能会认为这个职业的起源故事应该很有名。但事实是，我交谈过的大多数急救医疗技术员（EMT）从未听说过“自由之家”的护理人员，
or understand what we owe them. Today, it's easy to take what paramedics do for granted. Call 911 and they'll arrive with cardiac monitors, airway equipment, and an array of pharmaceuticals to treat anything from heart attacks to gunshots to premature births. But for a long time, emergency medical service, or what today is called EMS, didn't provide anything resembling that. In the early days of what we would view as EMS, it really wasn't the equivalent of what we see today.
也不了解我们欠他们什么。今天，人们很容易把护理人员所做的工作视为理所当然。拨打911，他们就会带着心脏监护仪、气道设备和各种药物赶到，治疗从心脏病发作到枪伤再到早产的各种病症。但在很长一段时间里，急救医疗服务（即今天的EMS）并没有提供任何类似的服务。在我们今天所理解的EMS早期，它确实不是我们今天所看到的那样。
They would do whatever it was they knew to do, but, you know, were they doing the right thing? Who knows? That's Richard Clinchy, he's the president of the EMS Museum and the trained paramedic. Clinchy says that when he started and emergency care in the late 50s, emergency services didn't provide treatment at the scene, or even necessarily on a way to the hospital. They were just about getting you to the hospital as quickly as possible. Which kind of makes sense in a way it is after all where the doctors are.
他们会做他们所知道的一切，但是，你知道，他们做的是对的吗？谁知道呢？那是理查德·克林奇，他是EMS博物馆的馆长，也是一名受过培训的护理人员。克林奇说，当他在50年代末开始从事急救护理时，急救服务并不在现场提供治疗，甚至在去医院的路上也不一定提供。他们只是想尽快把你送到医院。这在某种程度上是有道理的，毕竟医生都在那里。
But as a result, it often wasn't clear whose responsibility possible. Which kind of makes sense in a way it is after all where the doctors are. But as a result, it often wasn't clear whose responsibility it was to rush to the scene of an accident. Before the evolution of the MS, who did you call? Well, I was a paid firefighter back in the 60s and sometimes we got the call. If somebody needed a fire truck and they see it in New York, there were fireboxes everywhere. You'd pull the handle and fire person will look fire-quip would show up. In other areas, the responsibility for transporting patients often fell to local funeral homes. So imagine that you're having a massive heart attack, your life's in the balance, and who rolls up to save you, two more titions in a hurry. In many major cities, this crucial task fell to another municipal service that probably
但结果是，往往不清楚到底是谁的责任去赶往事故现场。在EMS发展之前，你打给谁？嗯，我在60年代是一名带薪消防员，有时我们会接到电话。如果有人需要消防车，在纽约，到处都有火警箱。你拉动把手，消防人员就会出现。在其他地区，运送病人的责任通常落在当地的殡仪馆身上。所以想象一下，你正在经历严重的心脏病发作，生命垂危，而赶来救你的是两个匆忙赶来的殡葬业者。在许多大城市，这项关键任务落在了另一个市政部门身上，而他们
had even less business responding to medical emergencies. The police. In the area where I was a firefighter, we had a police department that had a 57 Chevrolet wagon. That was an emergency response vehicle. So the idea, the general public was faced with was more less what I would call swoop and scoop, which simply meant that you'd call the police that rushed the person out there to you and then they'd pick you up,
可能更不适合应对医疗紧急情况。警察。在我当消防员的地区，我们有一个警察局，他们有一辆57年的雪佛兰旅行车。那就是急救车。所以，公众面临的理念更多的是我所说的“俯冲和铲起”，这意味着你打电话给警察，他们冲到你那里，然后把你捡起来，
put you in the back and rush you back down to the hospital. With minimal training and equipment, John Moon's police departments could do little more than offer patients basic first aid, a canvas stretcher, a half empty oxygen tank, and a pillow. Which more often than not, only serve to choke off the patient's airway. And on top of that, both individual, meaning police officers, got up front and left you back there by yourself. So if you stop breathing by the time you arrived, you were perhaps DOA because no one had done anything for you.
把你扔进后座，然后飞速送回医院。由于缺乏培训和设备，约翰·穆恩所在的警察局几乎只能提供基本的急救、帆布担架、半空的氧气瓶和一个枕头。而这些东西往往只会阻塞病人的气道。最重要的是，两个警察都坐在前排，把你一个人留在后面。所以如果你在到达医院时停止了呼吸，你可能已经死亡（DOA），因为没有人为你做任何事。
The police simply didn't have the tools, the training, or the disposition to save people in a medical emergency. But in the absence of a dedicated emergency medical service, the job was being left to them by default. And perhaps nowhere was the problem of relying on the police for help, more vividly illustrated than in Pittsburgh's largely black hill district. Moon says the city's mostly white police force was often slow to respond to emergencies in the hill, or the black residents, for their part, were reluctant to even call the place
警察根本没有工具、培训或意愿在医疗紧急情况下救人。但在缺乏专门的急救医疗服务的情况下，这项工作默认留给了他们。也许在匹兹堡以黑人为主的希尔区，这种依赖警察求助的问题表现得最为生动。穆恩说，该市以白人为主的警察部队在希尔区应对紧急情况时往往反应迟缓，而黑人居民则不愿打电话给警察。
to begin with. Because there was a trust issue with the police, primarily because there were no constraints. I mean, they could do whatever they wanted, and there was no repercussion, consequences for their actions. No one wanted to get into the exact same police van that the cops had threatened to throw them in the day before. So there was issues all the way around. Do I really want to call the police?
因为存在信任问题，主要是因为警察没有任何约束。我的意思是，他们可以为所欲为，而且他们的行为没有任何后果。没人想坐进前一天警察威胁要把他们扔进去的那种警车里。所以到处都是问题。我真的想打给警察吗？
Chances are they're going to take their time getting here number one and if I wait too long Then chances are a cap won't come to my neighborhood primarily because of fear of being robbed of what the case says so the options were very limited Doing that time and the same was true to varying degrees in the rest of the country committed, doing that time. And the same was true to varying degrees in the rest of the country. Whether in neighborhood was served by the police, or the fire department, or the local funeral home, so long as the priority was transportation, as opposed to treatment, no one even realized that there was a job that needed doing.
首先，他们很可能会磨磨蹭蹭才到，如果我等太久，出租车可能因为害怕被抢劫而不会来我的社区。所以在那段时间里，选择非常有限。在全国其他地区，情况也大同小异。无论社区是由警察、消防部门还是当地殡仪馆提供服务，只要优先考虑的是运输而不是治疗，就没人意识到还有一项工作需要完成。
But then, in the mid-60s, something happened which flipped the paradigm for emergency care on its head and laid the groundwork for the invention of paramedicin. In 1966, the federal government published a white paper that would prove so influential that even now in EMS circles it is simply called the white paper. Basically, it told us we were killing over 50,000 people a year on the highways and doing so unnecessarily that there was a way to intervene and save those people.
但后来，在60年代中期，发生了一件事，彻底颠覆了急救护理的模式，并为护理人员职业的诞生奠定了基础。1966年，联邦政府发布了一份白皮书，其影响力之大，以至于即使在今天的EMS圈子里，它也被简称为“白皮书”。基本上，它告诉我们，我们每年在公路上有超过5万人死亡，而且这种死亡是不必要的，有一种方法可以干预并拯救这些人。
But we didn't have the people, nor the resources, nor the training to do a whole lot about it. Techniques practiced by combat medics overseas had been largely ignored by the medical community. With the result that a person was more likely to die of a gunshot wound in America than on a battlefield in Vietnam. The white paper shamed the government into providing money for EMS development on the local level. And government officials and local community leaders began searching for solutions, including a community organizer in Pittsburgh named Phil Hallen. Oh my god, why do I do this?
但我们没有人员、资源或培训来做太多事情。海外战斗医护人员实践的技术在很大程度上被医学界忽视了。结果是，一个人在美国死于枪伤的可能性比在越南战场上还要大。这份白皮书羞辱了政府，促使其为地方层面的EMS发展提供资金。政府官员和当地社区领袖开始寻找解决方案，其中包括匹兹堡的一位社区组织者，名叫菲尔·哈伦。天哪，我为什么要这么做？
Hallen is a former ambulance attendant who came to Pittsburgh in the early 60s and yes, he hates being interviewed. Okay, how long are we going to be going on this? I can't, I don't last very long at age 90. Alan ran a civil rights organization called the Maurice Falk Medical Fund which examined health disparities due to institutional racism, and he immediately focused his eye on the city's pitiful emergency services. What was your impression of the level of care that was available in Pittsburgh?
哈伦是一位前救护车服务员，60年代初来到匹兹堡，是的，他讨厌接受采访。好吧，我们要谈多久？我年纪大了，坚持不了太久，我已经90岁了。哈伦经营着一个名为“莫里斯·福克医学基金”的民权组织，该组织研究因制度性种族主义导致的健康差异，他立即将目光投向了该市可怜的急救服务。你对匹兹堡当时可用的护理水平有什么印象？
Well, it wasn't my impression of it. It was the way it was. There was a netly level of care. There was no such thing as emergency medicine or any of the things we now look back on it. I think what the hell was going on. No, there was nothing. I mean nobody was straight. Especially the cops. He could see that what was going on was effectively a public health crisis that was disproportionately affecting black neighborhoods. But then one day, Helen came across an article in the local paper about a black operated jobs training program based in the Hill District called Freedom House. The article described how Freedom House had rolled out a kind of mobile grocery store for black neighborhoods using trucks to bring fresh vegetables to people's doors. And, well, healthcare is terrible in the Hill District. We have to do
嗯，这不是我的印象，这就是事实。那是一种极其低下的护理水平。根本没有所谓的急救医学，也没有我们现在回顾时所看到的任何东西。我想当时到底发生了什么。不，什么都没有。我的意思是没人受过训练。尤其是警察。他能看出正在发生的事情实际上是一场公共卫生危机，对黑人社区的影响尤为严重。但有一天，哈伦在当地报纸上看到了一篇关于希尔区一个由黑人运营的就业培训项目“自由之家”的文章。文章描述了“自由之家”如何利用卡车为黑人社区提供一种移动杂货店，将新鲜蔬菜送到人们家门口。而且，嗯，希尔区的医疗保健太糟糕了。我们必须做
something. If we could run a grocery van around, why can't we run a medical van around or something like that? Helen wasn't envisioning anything like modern emergency medical services. At first, he just thought Freedom House's trucks could help transport people and underserved neighborhoods to the hospital and that they could hire people from the Hill District to drive them. But that's what I got the director of the University Hospital on this group as well. And you know before the first meeting was over he said oh my God we have to go immediately to SAFER. The experimental study you are about to see is one of 18 similar studies during which we
点什么。如果我们能开着杂货车到处跑，为什么不能开着医疗车到处跑呢？哈伦最初并没有设想任何像现代急救医疗服务那样的东西。起初，他只是认为“自由之家”的卡车可以帮助将服务不足社区的人们送到医院，并且他们可以雇佣希尔区的人来驾驶。但我让大学医院的院长也加入了这个小组。你知道，在第一次会议结束前，他说，天哪，我们必须立即去SAFER。你即将看到的实验研究是18项类似研究之一，期间我们
compared various methods of artificial respiration. Dr. Peter SAFER was a head of anesthesiology at University of Pittsburgh, and by that time he was already famous in medical circles. Saffer was a pure scientist and a very precise and impatient Austrian. We simulated field conditions by selecting as subjects men and women of various body types. This is a film of Saffer from 1951 demonstrating a new technique he developed for resuscitation. What today we call CPR. To help orient you, we have made a diagram of the experimental set up. SAFER understood that, to be effective, resuscitation needed to be started immediately by the first
比较了各种人工呼吸方法。彼得·萨弗医生是匹兹堡大学麻醉学系主任，当时他在医学界已经很有名了。萨弗是一位纯粹的科学家，也是一位非常严谨且缺乏耐心的奥地利人。我们通过选择不同体型的人作为受试者来模拟现场条件。这是一部1951年萨弗演示他开发的一种复苏新技术的影片。也就是我们今天所说的CPR。为了帮助你理解，我们制作了实验设置的图表。萨弗明白，要有效，复苏必须由现场的第一个人立即开始，
person on the scene, but he faced heavy resistance from the medical community, which felt the general public couldn't be trusted with such specialized knowledge. So, SAFER performed an experiment. By anesthetizing and curing these subjects, we simulated LIMP asphyxia victims. SAFER paralyzed a group of volunteers using a chemical compound from the Amazon, normally used on poison dip deros. This is the same medical testing has changed a lot. Once the volunteers could no longer breathe on their own, SAFER had untrained lay people use CPR to keep those volunteers alive.
但他遭到了医学界的强烈抵制，他们认为不能信任普通公众掌握这种专业知识。所以，萨弗做了一个实验。通过麻醉这些受试者，我们模拟了肢体窒息受害者。萨弗使用一种来自亚马逊的化学化合物麻痹了一组志愿者，这种化合物通常用于毒箭。这是同样的医学测试，已经改变了很多。一旦志愿者无法自行呼吸，萨弗就让未经训练的普通人使用CPR来维持这些志愿者的生命。
And when I say untrained lay people, I mean children. This boy scout will perform mouth-to-airway breathing. Ultimately, SAFER's views would be vindicated, and for his effort, he'd forever be known as the father of CPR. Helen already knew some of this when he walked into Peter's saffer's office in 1966, but nothing could have prepared him for what actually happened. Within seconds of greeting Helen and the Freedom House team,
当我说是未经训练的普通人时，我是指孩子。这个童子军将进行口对气道呼吸。最终，萨弗的观点得到了证实，由于他的努力，他将永远被称为“CPR之父”。哈伦在1966年走进彼得·萨弗的办公室时已经知道了一些情况，但没有什么能让他为实际发生的事情做好准备。在问候哈伦和“自由之家”团队后的几秒钟内，
the wiry and energetic energetic safer began to unleash a torrent of ideas. Basically, he said, you are just what I'm looking for. I've been trying to figure out how to take rescue breathing and the rest out on the street and to train people how to do that. You got the people.
精干而充满活力的萨弗开始倾泻出一连串的想法。基本上，他说，你们正是我们要找的人。我一直在想如何把救援呼吸和其他技术带到街头，并培训人们如何做到这一点。你们有人手。
But safer didn't stop there. He wasn't content to just teach some van driver CPR. I said, let's go beyond that. Let's train them to be professionals as well. Professionals who could provide high quality medical care before the person was even taken to the hospital. It was not go to the scene, pick up a patient, transport to a hospital, and then start carrying
但萨弗并没有就此止步。他不满足于只教一些货车司机CPR。我说，让我们超越这一点。让我们也把他们训练成专业人员。那些能够在病人被送往医院之前就提供高质量医疗护理的专业人员。这不是去现场、接病人、运送到医院，然后开始护理，
it was emergency treatment right there on the paper. Instead of repurposed cargo spaces, SAFER argued that ambulances should be mobile intensive care units staffed by professionals trained to use cardiac monitors, administer medication, and anything else that might keep a patient alive. Halen and the others could barely keep up. Safer wasn't proposing a simple update to the existing system,
而是就在现场进行紧急治疗。萨弗认为，救护车不应该只是改装的货运空间，而应该是移动重症监护室，由受过培训的专业人员配备，能够使用心脏监护仪、给药以及任何其他可能维持病人生命的东西。哈伦和其他人几乎跟不上他的节奏。萨弗提出的不是对现有系统的简单更新，
but to change the whole culture of pre-hospital care. And he wanted to do it using Freedom House. I think somebody said, well, how big? What are we talking about here? He said, I can teach, I can remember this. I can instruct 40 people and you know, inside of a half an hour, we realized that there was something going on here which was way beyond anything that we had thought of.
而是要改变院前护理的整个文化。他想利用“自由之家”来实现这一目标。我想有人问，规模有多大？我们在谈论什么？他说，我可以教，我记得这个。我可以指导40个人，你知道，在半小时内，我们意识到这里发生的事情远远超出了我们所想的任何事情。
Saffer said about designing advanced ambulances and an intense 300 hour course whose graduates would be the world's first comprehensively trained first responders. This wasn't just the birth of a profession, but of a whole new branch of medicine. It would become a vital link in the chain with a subculture all its own. And the world's first fully trained barometics would be stabbed exclusively with young black men from the Hill District of Pittsburgh. And the people that worked there all were labeled unemployable.
萨弗着手设计先进的救护车和一门密集的300小时课程，其毕业生将成为世界上第一批受过全面培训的急救人员。这不仅是一个职业的诞生，也是整个医学新分支的诞生。它将成为链条中至关重要的一环，并拥有自己独特的亚文化。而世界上第一批受过全面培训的护理人员将完全由来自匹兹堡希尔区的年轻黑人男性组成。而那里工作的人都被贴上了“不可雇佣”的标签。
Freedom House recruited many of its first students right off the street, most of whom were just happy to land a good job, even if they were a little fuzzy on the details. John Moon wasn't part of that first class. He signed up a little later. But even he admits that as incredible as he thought the opportunity was, he didn't fully understand what he was getting into. On some level, he was just excited
“自由之家”从街头招募了许多第一批学生，他们大多数人只是很高兴能找到一份好工作，即使他们对细节有点模糊。约翰·穆恩不是第一批学员。他报名晚了一些。但即使是他也承认，尽管他认为这个机会不可思议，但他并不完全理解自己正在参与什么。在某种程度上，他只是很兴奋
to finally be wearing the uniform with the cool emblem that he saw on the first night. I'll put it this way. If someone bought you a thousand dollars suit and just gave it to you and Said just walk up and down the street in it. How would you feel? That's the way I felt I was at the point where okay, I got this uniform That's all it takes to help people and boy was I wrong It took a little bit more than that Um, that's how it takes to help people. And boy was our wrong.
终于能穿上他在第一晚看到的那个带有酷炫徽章的制服了。我这样说吧。如果有人给你买了一套一千美元的西装，直接送给你，然后说，穿着它在街上走走。你会感觉如何？我当时就是那种感觉，我心想，好吧，我有这套制服了，这就是帮助别人所需要的全部，天哪，我错了。这需要的不止这些。
It took a little bit more than that. After they signed up, moon and the others underwent a battery of psychological evaluations and interviews with medical professionals. They learned anatomy, physiology, CPR, advanced first aid, nursing and defensive driving at first under SAFER, but later under freedom houses first medical director, a 30-year-old white doctor with no previous ambulance experience named Nancy Caroline. And we look at her with skepticism because you have to remember she's not black, but once we found out that her heart was with us, that was really nothing she could do wrong.
这需要的不止这些。报名后，穆恩和其他人接受了一系列心理评估和医疗专业人员的面试。他们学习了解剖学、生理学、CPR、高级急救、护理和防御性驾驶，起初是在萨弗的指导下，但后来是在“自由之家”的第一任医疗主任——一位30岁的白人女医生南希·卡罗琳的指导下。我们带着怀疑的眼光看着她，因为你必须记住她不是黑人，但一旦我们发现她的心和我们在一起，她就真的没什么做错的了。
In everywhere she went, she took us with her. Caroline got the trainees access to almost every department of the hospital. She had them work in the morgue, the anesthesiology, suite, and the maternity ward. And of course, if they were going to bring the ICU to the street, they had to master everything that happened in an ICU. So that included spinal immobilization, cervical immobilization, IV insertion, and the advantages of classroom training for us at that particular time is we would learn a procedure in class or she would teach it to us.
无论她去哪里，她都带着我们。卡罗琳让学员们进入医院的几乎每个部门。她让他们在太平间、麻醉套房和产房工作。当然，如果他们要把ICU带到街头，他们必须掌握ICU里发生的一切。所以这包括脊柱固定、颈椎固定、静脉注射，而当时课堂培训对我们来说的好处是，我们会在课堂上学习一个程序，或者她会教给我们。
And then we would go out a half hour, 45 minutes later after we got out of class and perform that procedure on the person. In Freedom House Paramedics, we're often the first people to perform that procedure outside of hospital. They were among the first to use narcan to reverse an overdose, and the first to save a patient by shocking their heart in the field. Moon told me that the biggest first he personally experienced came in a call where Nancy Caroline was riding along. It was a patient having trouble breathing. He was unconscious.
然后我们在下课半小时、45分钟后就会出去，在病人身上执行那个程序。“自由之家”的护理人员往往是第一批在医院外执行该程序的人。他们是第一批使用纳洛酮（Narcan）来逆转过量用药的人，也是第一批通过在现场电击心脏来挽救病人的人。穆恩告诉我，他个人经历的最大的“第一次”是在一次有南希·卡罗琳随行的出诊中。那是一个呼吸困难的病人。他昏迷了。
So Moon started calling it in, but then Nancy Caroline stopped him. And, lo and behold, she said, start and I be an interbait, this patient. And I said, repeat that, since it's start and I be an interbait, this patient. Moon thinks he was the first paramedic who has ever asked to intubate someone in the field. I wasn't able to confirm that, but intubation, the subtle, but critical art of snaking a breathing tube into a patient's trachea
所以穆恩开始呼叫，但南希·卡罗琳阻止了他。瞧，她说，开始静脉注射并插管，这个病人。我说，重复一遍，是开始静脉注射并插管，这个病人。穆恩认为他是第一个被要求在现场为病人插管的护理人员。我无法证实这一点，但插管——将呼吸管插入病人气管的微妙但关键的艺术——
is an incredibly difficult procedure. I've gone through the training. It's not easy, even in a hospital setting. And here they were doing it on the sidewalk. Moon says he was scared to setting. And here they were doing it on the sidewalk. Moon says you've scared to death. And once I gathered my nerves together and remembered how she had taught us in the anatomy lab, I went ahead and did it.
是一个极其困难的程序。我经历过培训。这并不容易，即使在医院环境中也是如此。而他们当时是在人行道上做这件事。穆恩说他当时吓坏了。一旦我鼓起勇气，记起她在解剖实验室教我们的方法，我就继续做了。
And once I interviewed the person and took him to the emergency room, I had to deal with the ER doctor saying, well, who, who, who, who caused them to be interpreted? And I said, I did. And you are. I said, well, my name is John Moon and I'm a paramedic at Friedman San Francisco. But it wasn't enough for Moon and the other paramedics to simply master the techniques required for emergency medical care. Freedom house personnel faced an even bigger challenge from the moment
当我插管并把他送到急诊室时，我不得不面对急诊室医生问：“谁，谁，谁，谁让他插管的？”我说，我做的。你是谁？我说，我叫约翰·穆恩，我是“自由之家”的护理人员。但对于穆恩和其他护理人员来说，仅仅掌握急救医疗护理所需的技能是不够的。“自由之家”的人员从接到电话的那一刻起就面临着更大的挑战。
they got the call. The city had contracted with Freedom House to handle calls in Pittsburgh's mostly black neighborhoods in the downtown area, but the Pittsburgh police dispatchers often refused to send them. Because the police looked at us as someone taking their jobs away, but Freedom House looked at the police as being a threat to the patient. And one of the things that we had to put in place is we used a police scanner. And we would monitor the calls, and we
市政府与“自由之家”签订了合同，负责处理匹兹堡以黑人为主的社区和市中心的电话，但匹兹堡的警察调度员经常拒绝派他们去。因为警察把我们看作是抢他们饭碗的人，而“自由之家”则把警察看作是对病人的威胁。我们必须采取的一项措施是使用警察扫描仪。我们会监控电话，
would subsequently try to get to the scene before they did. Moon recalls getting to the scene just seconds after the police arrived and seeing them try to drag patients out of wreck cars. And here we are saying, no you can't do this, let's put them on a spine board and put a cervical collar on them. But remember, these were a bunch of black guys from the hill lecturing mostly white cops. You know, and we're yelling at them. And they're cussing us out. Sometimes the police would relent. But other times they would threaten the paramedics with a rest unless they backed off.
随后尽量在他们到达之前赶到现场。穆恩回忆说，在警察到达几秒钟后赶到现场，看到他们试图把病人从失事车辆中拖出来。“我们在这里说，不，你们不能这样做，让我们把他们放在脊柱板上，给他们戴上颈托。”但请记住，这是一群来自希尔区的黑人小伙子在教训大多数白人警察。你知道，我们在对他们大喊大叫。而他们在咒骂我们。有时警察会妥协。但其他时候，他们会威胁要逮捕护理人员，除非他们退后。
And you know, the only thing you can do is just stand back and say, okay, and then you watch them drag the individual out of the car and put them in the back of a paddy wagon and both guys get up front and they race off to the hospital. So those were oftentimes battles that you were not going to win. And it wasn't just the cops who didn't understand. Patients couldn't fathom why Moon was using a cardiac monitor and starting IVs in their house instead of herring them to a doctor. Their idea was let's call the ambulance.
你知道，你唯一能做的就是退后一步说，好吧，然后你看着他们把那个人从车里拖出来，扔进警车的后座，两个警察都坐到前排，飞速赶往医院。所以这些往往是你无法赢的战斗。而且不仅仅是警察不理解。病人们无法理解为什么穆恩在他们家里使用心脏监护仪并进行静脉注射，而不是把他们送到医生那里。他们的想法是，打给救护车。
The ambulance comes and pick you up and take you to the hospital. That's all they knew. And it wasn't the easiest thing in the world to explain to a family member that we have brought the emergency room to the person. Trying to convince white patients to submit to treatment was especially difficult. Some wouldn't even let the black paramedics touch them. That was found upon on more than one occasion, where they would say, no, do you have to really do this? I would prefer that you not do it. And it's something that we had to endure, because the problem
救护车来接你，把你送到医院。他们只知道这些。向家庭成员解释我们已经把急诊室带到了病人身边，这并不是世界上最容易的事情。试图说服白人病人接受治疗尤其困难。有些人甚至不让黑人护理人员碰他们。这种情况不止一次发生，他们会说，不，你真的必须这样做吗？我宁愿你不要这样做。这是我们必须忍受的，因为问题
was not with us. The problem was with the patient. It was their belief or their preconceived notion about the individuals that were touching them. The same went for doctors and nurses at any hospital not directly affiliated with SAFER and the Freedom House program. Moon remembers trying to read a patient's vital signs, only to have a nurse laugh in his face as if he was pretending to play doctor. Other Freedom House paramedics were mistaken for orderlies and asked to mop the floor. But despite all the struggle, Freedom House's reputation was growing.
不在我们身上。问题在于病人。这是他们对接触他们的个人的信念或先入为主的观念。对于那些不直接隶属于萨弗和“自由之家”项目的医院的医生和护士来说，情况也是如此。穆恩记得他试图读取病人的生命体征，却被一名护士嘲笑，好像他在假装扮演医生。其他“自由之家”的护理人员被误认为是护工，被要求去拖地。但尽管困难重重，“自由之家”的名声还是越来越大。
People were beginning to recognize that something really different was going on here. This wasn't just called the ambulance. Phil Hallen says stories started to spread about an ambulance service that could perform miraculous life-saving procedures at the scene of horrific accidents. Perhaps the most influential story was about a kid on his bike who was hit head on by a car. The accident was in Squirrel Hill, one of the city's most affluent neighborhoods, and one that Freedom House had never been allowed to enter. So initially, the dispatcher sent the police, but the cops panicked.
人们开始意识到这里正在发生一些真正不同的事情。这不仅仅是叫救护车。菲尔·哈伦说，关于一个能够在可怕事故现场执行奇迹般救生程序的救护车服务的故事开始流传。也许最有影响力的故事是关于一个骑自行车的孩子被汽车正面撞倒。事故发生在松鼠山，这是该市最富裕的社区之一，也是“自由之家”从未被允许进入的社区。所以起初，调度员派了警察，但警察惊慌失措。
The kid was bleeding out in front of them and they had no idea what to do. And somebody said, get freedom house up here. And they did a miraculous activity, which nobody had ever seen, and they'd take place on the street before. People watched it happen. And that was a basic turning point. By this time, Freedom House's five ambulances were running nearly 6,000 calls a year and providing demonstrably better care. At a City Council meeting, SAFER presented data showing that as many as
孩子在他们面前流血不止，他们不知道该怎么办。有人说，把“自由之家”叫来。他们做了一项奇迹般的活动，这是以前从未见过的，而且是在街上发生的。人们看着它发生。那是一个基本的转折点。到那时，“自由之家”的五辆救护车每年处理近6000个电话，并提供明显更好的护理。在市议会会议上，萨弗展示的数据显示，每年有多达
1,200 people a year had been dying needlessly while in the care of other emergency services. Freedom House paramedics, by contrast, had saved 200 lives in the first year alone. Doctors and medical directors from around the country flocked to Pittsburgh. Freedom House medics were invited to conferences as far away as Germany. Everyone wanted to see what they were doing and learn how they could copy it. In 1975, the federal government chose Freedom House to field test the first standardized training curriculum
1200人因其他急救服务的护理不当而无谓死亡。“自由之家”的护理人员相比之下，仅第一年就挽救了200人的生命。来自全国各地的医生和医疗主任涌向匹兹堡。“自由之家”的医护人员受邀参加远至德国的会议。每个人都想看看他们在做什么，并学习如何复制它。1975年，联邦政府选择“自由之家”来实地测试第一个标准化的培训课程
for EMS providers. And Nancy Caroline was asked to write the textbook. But Freedom House's growing reputation would ultimately prove to be its greatest liability. The more successes they chalked up, the more certain residents and city officials wanted to see Freedom House gone. And according to John Moon, it was for a simple reason.
供EMS提供者使用。南希·卡罗琳被要求编写教科书。但“自由之家”日益增长的名声最终被证明是它最大的负担。他们取得的成功越多，某些居民和城市官员就越想让“自由之家”消失。据约翰·穆恩说，原因很简单。
How dare you have an EMS system or an ambulance service, this good serving the Black economically deprived community or as society says those people. And we don't have anything like that. And perhaps no one did more to punish freedom house for this transgression than Pittsburgh's mayor. Elected in 1969, 45-year-old Pete Flairity was a fiscally conservative Democrat. Tall and broad-shouldered, he went into office already believing programs using taxpayer money should be managed entirely by the city But ask Phil Hallen and he'll tell you he believes that the mayor's beef with freedom house went beyond issues of fiscal or bureaucratic turf What was his opinion of freedom house?
你怎么敢拥有一个如此优秀的EMS系统或救护车服务，为黑人经济贫困社区或社会所说的“那些人”服务？而我们却没有那样的东西。也许没有人比匹兹堡市长更严厉地惩罚“自由之家”的这种“越轨”行为了。1969年当选的45岁的皮特·弗莱里蒂是一位财政保守的民主党人。他身材高大，肩膀宽阔，上任时就认为使用纳税人钱的项目应该完全由市政府管理。但问问菲尔·哈伦，他会告诉你，他认为市长与“自由之家”的矛盾超出了财政或官僚地盘的问题。他对“自由之家”的看法是什么？
Well, I didn't like it particularly because it was it was doing too well. That was black And you think that's why's why he felt that way? I think so. Was it your opinion that he was racist? Yes. When Flarity took office, he slashed Freedom House's operating budget in half. This didn't leave enough money to cover even routine
嗯，他不喜欢它，特别是因为它做得太好了。那是黑人的。你认为这就是他有这种感觉的原因吗？我想是这样。你认为他是种族主义者吗？是的。当弗莱里蒂上任时，他将“自由之家”的运营预算削减了一半。这甚至没有足够的钱来支付救护车的日常
maintenance on the ambulances. Caroline repeatedly wrote frustrated missives to Freedom House's board complaining about breaks and steering that locked up, doors that fell from the hinges and seats that toppled over. Once, according to Caroline, an engine caught fire while transporting a patient. Flirty passed an ordinance that banned ambulances from using their sirens in certain neighborhoods, which significantly slowed their response times. And I first I'll say you can't use a siren downtown because people are complaining about it.
维护。卡罗琳多次向“自由之家”的董事会写信表达沮丧，抱怨刹车和转向系统锁死、门从铰链上掉下来以及座椅翻倒。据卡罗琳说，有一次，在运送病人时发动机着火了。弗莱里蒂通过了一项法令，禁止救护车在某些社区使用警笛，这大大减慢了他们的响应时间。起初我会说你不能在市中心使用警笛，因为人们在抱怨它。
Unfortunately, people look in the vehicle to see who's driving it and then they complain. So we're going on the call downtown and you have to blow your horn to tell the car to get out of the way. And they're looking at you like you're crazy. Rumors were spread that Freedom House paramedics were selling drugs and running dice games from the ambulances and that thousands of dollars had
不幸的是，人们往车里看，看看是谁在开车，然后他们就抱怨。所以我们去市中心出诊，你必须按喇叭告诉车让开。他们看着你，就像你疯了一样。有谣言称“自由之家”的护理人员在救护车上卖毒品和玩骰子游戏，而且有数千美元从总部
been stolen from headquarters. And it became a struggle after struggle after struggle and eventually, you know, it's it's almost like a patient struggling to breathe and eventually the heart gets tired and it stops beating and the person stops breathing and that's exactly what happened. In 1975 Flerdy struck a final devastating blow. He announced that the city would roll out its own brand-new paramedic service. Not announced that the city would roll out its own brand new paramedic service.
被偷走了。这变成了一场又一场的斗争，最终，你知道，这就像一个病人挣扎着呼吸，最终心脏累了，停止跳动，人停止呼吸，这正是发生的事情。1975年，弗莱里蒂发出了最后致命的一击。他宣布市政府将推出自己全新的护理人员服务。
Not only was the new service showered with the resources Freedom House had long been denied, its recruits were all white. The city needed Caroline to serve as its medical director, and she used that leverage to make one demand that the Freedom House crews be hired on. Flaherty relented. Sort of. Because the city was required to bring the employees over, but they were not required to keep them. So they found a way to get rid of them. So, you know, that's how the city system ended up being 98% it. White when the first EMS system in this country was African-American. Within a few years of being replaced by the city's EMS service, Freedom House was more less forgotten. In part because, like all good things, Paramedics were soon taken for granted. Today, it never occurs to anyone to ask where paramedicine came from. But to Phil Hallen that's the true measure of freedom
新服务不仅获得了“自由之家”长期被拒绝的资源，而且其新兵全是白人。市政府需要卡罗琳担任其医疗主任，她利用这一筹码提出了一个要求：雇佣“自由之家”的员工。弗莱里蒂妥协了。算是吧。因为市政府被要求接收这些员工，但他们没有被要求留住他们。所以他们找到了摆脱他们的方法。所以，你知道，这就是为什么城市系统最终有98%是白人，而这个国家第一个EMS系统是非裔美国人的。在被城市EMS服务取代后的几年里，“自由之家”几乎被遗忘了。部分原因是，像所有美好的事物一样，护理人员很快就被视为理所当然。今天，没人会想到问护理人员职业是从哪里来的。但对菲尔·哈伦来说，这是“自由之家”遗产的真正衡量标准。
house's legacy. Paramedicine is just there. You know do you know anybody that doesn't take this for granted at this point in any American city or even in the American countryside? I mean that nobody would even think of a time when somebody would not survive because they couldn't, that somebody didn't know how to do CPR. It's unthinkable anywhere in the United States. The model of care created at Freedom House ended up being adopted by countless other paramedics programs across the country, very often with the help of Freedom House veterans. Peter Safr, helped to develop a paramedic program in Baltimore.
护理人员就在那里。你知道，在任何美国城市甚至美国乡村，你知道有谁不把这视为理所当然吗？我的意思是，没人会想到一个时代，有人因为不知道如何做CPR而无法幸存。这在美国任何地方都是不可想象的。“自由之家”创造的护理模式最终被全国无数其他护理人员项目所采用，通常是在“自由之家”老兵的帮助下。彼得·萨弗帮助开发了巴尔的摩的护理人员项目。
Mitchell Brown, another Freedom House alum, became the EMS Commissioner for the City of Cleveland and later its director of public safety. In Nancy Caroline, founded the first ever EMS service in Israel. Her textbook, titled Emergency Care in the Streets, ended up setting the first ever EMS service in Israel. Her textbook titled Emergency Care in the Streets ended up setting the standard and EMS instruction for decades. As for Moon, he stayed with Pittsburgh EMS and retired in 2009 as an assistant chief. How does he feel about it all now? When he looks back on the days when a handful of young men from the Hill made history. It's something that I'm extremely, extremely proud to have been a part of.
米切尔·布朗，另一位“自由之家”校友，成为了克利夫兰市的EMS专员，后来成为其公共安全主任。南希·卡罗琳在以色列创立了第一个EMS服务。她的教科书《街头急救护理》最终设定了EMS教学的标准，持续了几十年。至于穆恩，他留在了匹兹堡EMS，并于2009年以助理局长的身份退休。他现在对此有何感想？当他回顾希尔区的一小群年轻人创造历史的日子时。这是我感到非常、非常自豪能参与其中的事情。
And every time I see an EMS unit going down the street, I wonder, do they have any idea that's where it all began, because it all getting there. Kevin and I discuss what lessons the surprisingly recent history of paramedicine might offer people contemplating a different role for police in our public safety infrastructure today. After this. Okay, so I'm now talking with Kevin Hazard who reported that story for us and you are a paramedic. I think that's interesting to know. How did you get into being a paramedic? Basically, after 9-11, I was working as a reporter
每次我看到一辆EMS车在街上行驶，我都在想，他们知道这一切是从哪里开始的吗？因为这一切都在那里。凯文和我讨论了护理人员令人惊讶的近期历史可能为今天考虑警察在我们公共安全基础设施中不同角色的人们提供什么教训。稍后回来。好的，我现在正在和报道这个故事的凯文·哈扎德交谈，你是一名护理人员。我认为这很有趣。你是怎么成为护理人员的？基本上，在9-11之后，我当时是一名记者。
and a lot of my friends had been in the military and they had these crazy stories that they would tell. One of them was among the first Marines to enter into Iraq. And he's cruising along, talking about rockets, being fired from a helicopter so closely, he could feel a heat off of them. And I'm sitting in city council meetings and you know reporting on like the whether or not they should put speed bumps and various
我有很多朋友都在军队待过，他们会讲一些疯狂的故事。其中一个人是第一批进入伊拉克的陆战队员之一。他跟我讲，当时他坐着直升机，火箭弹就在旁边飞过，近到他能感觉到火箭弹散发的热量。而我当时坐在市议会会议上，你知道，报道着是否应该在各种街道上设置减速带之类的事情。
sub urban streets and I was just frustrated and bored and in one night I got sent by my editor to cover a tunnel collapse They were doing this huge infrastructure project in Atlanta and You know there were six guys on a scaffolding that dropped 250 feet into the earth, and we sat outside with the families and waited. And there were a group of paramedics that went down there, the sort of high-angle rescue team, and they were pelt down into the darkness, and we're all waiting and waiting and waiting. And finally, they emerged.
在郊区的街道上，我感到沮丧和无聊。有一天晚上，编辑派我去报道一起隧道坍塌事故。他们在亚特兰大进行一项巨大的基础设施工程，有六个人在脚手架上，坠落到了250英尺深的地下。我们和家属们坐在外面等待。有一群护理人员下去了，那是某种高角度救援队，他们被吊进黑暗中，我们都在等待，等待，再等待。最后，他们出来了。
And, you know, of course, the news is as bad as we anticipated it to be. But there was something in those guys and the way that they carried themselves and whatever it was that they saw once they disappeared into darkness of that whole, I just thought, whatever version of the truth that I'm looking for, I think those guys are carrying it somewhere within them. And so I just signed up for an EMT class completely on a lock and no idea if I even could finish it. And next thing, I'm sitting on an ambulance and I'm my way to some ridiculous call. It all happens somewhat accidentally. Yeah. I mean, it sounds pretty similar to the story that John Moon says. Of C's, someone being inspired of that as being in a vocation and that speaking to you in some way.
当然，新闻和我们预料的一样糟糕。但那些人身上有一种特质，他们举止的方式，以及无论他们在消失在那个洞穴的黑暗中时看到了什么，我都觉得，我所寻找的真相的某种版本，就在他们身上。于是我完全凭运气报名参加了急救员课程，根本不知道自己能不能完成。接下来，我就坐在救护车上，去处理一些荒谬的求助电话。这一切发生得有点偶然。是的，这听起来和约翰·穆恩说的故事很像。关于某人受到启发，将其视为一种天职，并以某种方式与你产生共鸣。
Did that story have particular resonance with you because of your own experience? Yeah, it did. I mean, if you get to the heart of John's story, you know, really he's a young guy who's looking for a way to prove himself in a world, you know, a particular two world that has ignored him. You know, and obviously my experience in life is vastly different from John's. But to me, I saw this group of people who were doing something that I thought that I could do. It didn't feel like an unattainable goal, but it felt like this incredible opportunity
那个故事是因为你自己的经历而让你产生特别的共鸣吗？是的，确实。如果你深入约翰故事的核心，他其实是一个年轻人，在一个忽视他的世界里寻找证明自己的方式。显然，我的人生经历和约翰的截然不同。但对我来说，我看到了一群人正在做我认为我也能做的事情。这感觉不是一个遥不可及的目标，而是一个不可思议的机会。
to do this sort of thing that I never anticipated, to have the opportunity to do. And, you know, so there was a lot in John's story that always felt, that always rang true to me. And what part of your career did you learn about this history about, you know, the first paramedics being black men from an underserved neighborhood in Pittsburgh, and this whole orchid story. No part. I think that's probably the the reason that you know John sits up at night, you know, filing his teeth and his his his Pittsburgh home. Nobody knows this when when I went to paramedic school, my instructor was one of the first six medics in the state of Georgia. And he was telling us these stories of the early days when he was riding a horse, you know, coming out of the funeral homes and they would embom bodies one night and then transport the next. And, you know, he did get a call and he sweep the flower petals out of the back of the horse and you rush off.
去做那种我从未预料到有机会做的事情。所以约翰的故事里有很多东西一直让我觉得，一直让我产生共鸣。你是在职业生涯的哪个阶段了解到这段历史的，关于第一批护理人员是来自匹兹堡服务不足社区的黑人，以及整个“自由之家”的故事？没有哪个阶段。我想这大概就是为什么约翰晚上睡不着觉，在匹兹堡的家里磨牙的原因。没人知道这件事。当我上急救员学校时，我的教练是佐治亚州最早的六名医护人员之一。他给我们讲了早期的故事，那时他开着灵车，从殡仪馆出来，他们晚上给尸体防腐，第二天就负责运送。他接到电话，把灵车后面的花瓣扫掉，然后就冲了出去。
So when you say sweeping out petals in the horse, he was one of those people sent by the funeral home to be an EMS person. Is that what you mean? Yeah, and much of Atlanta, the only people who are capable of transporting a body with a funeral home, right? They have how many people have something like a horse. And so he was a funeral home employee. And one night a week he would embomb bodies.
所以当你提到扫掉灵车里的花瓣时，他是殡仪馆派去当急救人员的人之一吗？你是这个意思吗？是的，在亚特兰大的大部分地区，唯一有能力运送尸体的人就是殡仪馆，对吧？他们有多少人有灵车之类的东西。所以他是一名殡仪馆员工。每周有一个晚上他会给尸体做防腐处理。
And then the next night he would be responsible for responding to emergency calls. And this was, you know, before there was any notion of a paramedic. So these guys had, you know, maybe 10 hours of first-aid training. And they're sitting down, you know, in the basement of the funeral home. Call comes in, they rush out, you know, again, they yank out, the casket sweep out the flower petals, slide in some sort of a stretcher, and then race the streets in a hearse which you know with these old Cadillac hearse and he said that if you got going too fast the brakes would soften up and you couldn't stop. So they're
然后第二天晚上，他就要负责响应紧急呼叫。这还是在“护理人员”这个概念出现之前。所以这些人可能只有10个小时的急救培训。他们坐在殡仪馆的地下室里，电话一响，他们就冲出去，再次把棺材拉出来，扫掉花瓣，滑进某种担架，然后开着灵车在街上狂奔，你知道，就是那种老式的凯迪拉克灵车。他说如果开得太快，刹车就会变软，你就停不下来了。所以他们
screaming this hearse with a purple light on its roof screaming through the city of Atlanta with no brakes. Flower pedals trailing out of the back window. Oh my goodness. That sounds like a totally different world. It's amazing that that's within our lifetimes. That's just amazing. It's not that long ago at all. Yeah. Yeah. And so hearing these stories of the early days when they carried a credit card machine with them and before they dropped a patient off the hospital, they'd slide it in front of them and say, Kess, check or charge. This really sort of wild west era in which nobody really knew what they were doing. But that was all I knew about it.
尖叫着开着这辆车顶上有紫色灯的灵车，在亚特兰大市狂奔，却没有刹车。花瓣从后窗飘出来。天哪。这听起来完全是另一个世界。真令人惊讶，这竟然发生在我们有生之年。这太令人惊奇了。这其实没过多久。是的。所以听到这些早期的故事，他们随身带着信用卡机，在把病人送到医院之前，他们会把机器推到病人面前说，现金、支票还是刷卡。这真的是一个狂野的西部时代，没人真正知道自己在做什么。但这确实是我所知道的全部。
It started out in a very, you know, slip shot sort of way and then slowly became serious. It wasn't until after my book came out that somebody said to me, you know, hey, there's another story, another EMS story, if you're ever looking for one, and it was said in Pittsburgh. And so I started googling it, and the only thing I could find were a handful of, you know, local press accounts, you know, of these, these, you know, young men and women who had done this thing in the late 60s and early 70s, and I started digging into it, and all of a sudden just the reality of what it was that had happened that nobody knew, you know. I know a paramedic from Pittsburgh who has no idea that this was the start of it all. And for no one to know that, it was shocking to me, particularly someone who
它开始时非常草率，然后慢慢变得严肃起来。直到我的书出版后，才有人对我说：“嘿，如果你还在找故事的话，还有另一个急救故事”，那是发生在匹兹堡的。于是我开始谷歌搜索，我能找到的只有少数几篇当地媒体的报道，关于这些在60年代末和70年代初做这件事的年轻人。我开始深入挖掘，突然间，发生的事情的真相竟然没人知道。我认识一个匹兹堡的急救员，他根本不知道这就是一切的开始。没人知道这一点，这让我感到震惊，尤其是对于一个
did it for a year and wrote about it. And that's when I got in touch with John and I said, how does nobody know this? And he just screamed, I know! Nobody knows! Oh, I'm so glad that we get to tell a story because it's amazing to me. And it's pretty resonant today. And particularly the role of police in both the story that you told and what's happening right now, there's this history there that we presented.
做了一年并写过它的人来说。就在那时，我联系了约翰，我说，怎么会没人知道这件事？他只是尖叫道：“我知道！没人知道！”哦，我很高兴我们能讲这个故事，因为它让我感到惊奇。而且它在今天非常有共鸣。特别是警察在你们讲的故事和现在发生的事情中所扮演的角色，我们呈现的这段历史中存在着这种联系。
That is, you know, the police were the kind of default person to be called in this type of emergency, even though they had, you know, no skills or inclination to do the job that was required. And we're looking at what policing means today. And what does it mean that a person potentially armed like a soldier is brought to a situation where someone had a stroke, for example, and maybe that isn't the right thing to do. And we had this discussion, or we, people had this discussion in the late 60s and 70s, too.
那就是，警察是这类紧急情况下的默认呼叫对象，尽管他们没有任何技能或意愿去完成所需的工作。我们正在审视今天的警务意味着什么。如果一个像士兵一样武装的人被带到一个有人中风的现场，这又意味着什么？也许这并不是正确的做法。我们在60年代末和70年代也进行过这样的讨论。
So when you think about the story you told in your experience, and you think about what the discussions are happening today, how do you take in the moment and reconcile it with this history that we told in this story? Yeah, you know, what's crazy about that is when I began researching this story, I was coming across quotes that really got to the heart of a conversation we're just now having today. And these are things that I was reading in the fall and spring of 2018 and 2019. The early medics who were out there saying,
所以当你思考你讲述的故事和你的经历，并思考今天正在发生的讨论时，你是如何看待当下并将其与我们在这个故事中讲述的历史相调和的呢？是的，你知道，疯狂的是，当我开始研究这个故事时，我发现了一些真正触及我们今天正在进行的对话核心的引语。这些是我在2018年秋季和2019年春季读到的东西。早期的医护人员当时说，
hey, if you want this police truck to show up at your house, you have to understand that last night, that was a truck that showed up to arrest your neighbor. Tomorrow night might be the truck to show up to arrest you. If you really think people are going to be comfortable calling that guy to arrive tonight, then you don't think you understand the situation we're living in. And there was a lot of pushback from, you know, the city of Pittsburgh, Allegating County about changing this system because it was the system that had always been and people thought it was works. And somebody was able to come along and prove that no, this isn't working and these guys aren't suited for this task. No, but I think what is valuable about these lessons of history, it's so recent that paramedics
嘿，如果你想让这辆警车出现在你家门口，你必须明白，昨晚，这辆车是去逮捕你邻居的。明天晚上它可能就是来逮捕你的。如果你真的认为人们会乐意叫那个人今晚过来，那你就不了解我们所处的情况。匹兹堡市和阿勒格尼县对改变这个系统有很多阻力，因为这是长期以来的系统，人们认为它有效。但有人站出来证明，不，这行不通，这些人并不适合这项任务。不，但我认为这些历史教训的价值在于，护理人员的出现是如此之近，
were invented. It's so surprisingly recent that it should free your mind to think of the possibilities of what infrastructure of public safety could be today if we didn't all want its arrest on the police and wanted to try something different. I would agree. I understand the resistance to it. I understand the fear that people feel when you say something like defund the police, it sounds like a really radical term.
它竟然如此令人惊讶地近，这应该能解放你的思想，去思考如果公共安全基础设施不完全依赖警察，我们今天可以尝试一些不同的东西，会有什么样的可能性。我同意。我理解对它的抵制。我理解当你说“削减警察经费”这样的话时人们感到的恐惧，这听起来是一个非常激进的词。
But if you can sit down and realize how often the police are called out because there's a psych patient who hasn't taken his medicine and his 76-year-old parents aren't certain what to do with him. And this police officer shows up, not saying to a hammer, everything looks like a nail. Well, unfortunately, the police really kind of, they're limited in terms of what they can do.
但如果你能坐下来意识到，警察被叫去处理是因为一个精神病人没吃药，而他76岁的父母不知道该怎么办，这种情况有多频繁。然后这个警察出现了，就像拿着锤子的人，看什么都像钉子。嗯，不幸的是，警察确实在他们能做的事情上受到了限制。
And one of the things I learned very quickly in doing that job was that the police can't lose a fight. You know, by the nature of their profession, they are back as against the wall. And once they arrive, they have to keep pushing forward. And oftentimes, that led to a situation that didn't need to happen. What could have been a situation that we had de-escalated, wound up escalating because the person that arrived with someone who had essentially,
我在做那份工作时很快学到的一件事是，警察不能输掉一场冲突。你知道，由于他们职业的性质，他们背水一战。一旦他们到达现场，他们就必须继续推进。通常情况下，这会导致本不该发生的情况。本来可以通过降级处理的情况，最终却升级了，因为到达现场的人本质上是，
if they didn't get cooperation, they only had one avenue that they could venture down. It's amazing to me to think, you know, when John Moon saw the paramedics for the first time, he'd never heard the word paramedic, you know? And it was completely novel to most people. And I'm thinking today about how we're thinking about the police and maybe how to sort of, you know, defund them or divest them of some of these activities,
如果他们得不到配合，他们只有一条路可以走。想到约翰·穆恩第一次见到护理人员时，他从未听说过“护理人员”这个词，这对我来说太神奇了。这对大多数人来说是全新的。我今天在想我们是如何看待警察的，也许是如何，你知道，削减他们的经费或剥离他们的一些活动，
which they're not suited towards. I think it's kind of interesting to imagine that there could be a word, you know, that is like a rapid response, social worker, mental health worker that is going to be sent out to people that will be a word like paramedic in 50 years. I mean, you thought about that? It feels like I have it. It feels like we're on the cusp of that moment. There's no doubt that people are looking for a new way for police to respond. It's something different to come out.
这些活动他们并不适合。我觉得想象一下，未来可能会有一个词，比如“快速反应社会工作者”、“心理健康工作者”，他们会被派往人们那里，就像50年后的“护理人员”一样，这很有趣。我是说，你想过吗？感觉我好像想过。感觉我们正处于那个时刻的边缘。毫无疑问，人们正在寻找一种新的警察响应方式。会有不同的东西出现。
The number of instances we've had in which these situations have gone wrong, how often it has been someone who's called out for a mental health issue or something that didn't initially appear to be a crime in progress. And you have to think that somebody out there and amidst all these, you know, defund the police conversation, someone must be saying, well, how else can we deploy these resources?
我们经历过多少次这种情况出错的例子，有多少次是因为有人因为心理健康问题或最初看起来不是正在发生的犯罪而被叫去处理。你不得不认为，在所有这些关于“削减警察经费”的对话中，一定有人在说，好吧，我们还能如何部署这些资源？
Who else can we bring to bear in these situations that can bring a better outcome? And there's probably a new job title, a new role, a whole new group of people that are sitting out there that not too long from now, we're all going to look back and say, well, of course, it's so obvious, naturally those guys are there, naturally those people are responding. How in earth did we live without them? And I think we're sort of at the moment where these things are born.
我们还能在这些情况下带来谁，从而带来更好的结果？可能有一个新的职位名称，一个新的角色，一大群新人正坐在那里，不久之后，我们所有人都会回过头来说，好吧，当然，这太明显了，这些人自然就在那里，这些人自然就在响应。我们到底是怎么没有他们活下来的？我认为我们正处于这些事物诞生的时刻。
Well, I think it's really interesting, and I'm so glad we're able to share this story. So thanks so much for talking with us and for reporting. That's been great. Thank you. It's really great to be here. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Kevin Hazard, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed-in tech production by Sarah McCarthy, and Sri Vyusev, music by Sean Real. Kurt Coleset is the digital director of the rest of the team, a senior editor to Lany Hall, Katie Mangle, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroube, Abby Madon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Many thanks to the atavist for sharing Kevin's original story with us. If you want to learn
嗯，我觉得这真的很有趣，我很高兴我们能分享这个故事。非常感谢你与我们交谈并进行报道。这太棒了。谢谢。能来到这里真是太好了。本周的《99% Invisible》由凯文·哈扎德制作，乔·罗森伯格编辑，萨拉·麦卡锡和斯里·维尤塞夫进行混音和技术制作，肖恩·里尔配乐。库尔特·科尔塞特是团队其余成员的数字总监，高级编辑包括拉尼·霍尔、凯蒂·曼格尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、艾比·马登、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我罗曼·马斯。非常感谢Atavist与我们分享凯文的原创故事。如果你想了解
more about the history of Freedom House, you should check out that article. If you want to learn more about Kevin's career as a paramedic, you should go read his memoir, it's called A Thousand Naked Strangers, bovelling to both on a website. We are a project of 91.7 K.A.L.W. in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which is distributed in multiple locations around North America, and in our hearts it will always be. In beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find us and support us all at radiotopia.fm, just like these fine people did, Emilio Martinez, Ashley Travers, Bill Worthin, Alison Myers, Elizabeth Camero, and John and Jen, who just
更多关于“自由之家”的历史，你应该看看那篇文章。如果你想了解更多关于凯文作为护理人员的职业生涯，你应该去读他的回忆录，书名叫《一千个裸体陌生人》，在网站上都有。我们是旧金山91.7 K.A.L.W.的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，在北美多个地点发行，在我们心中它永远是。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的骄傲成员，这是一个由世界上最创新、听众支持、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立的集体。请在radiotopia.fm找到并支持我们，就像这些优秀的人一样，埃米利奥·马丁内斯、阿什利·特拉弗斯、比尔·沃辛、艾莉森·迈尔斯、伊丽莎白·卡梅罗，以及约翰和简，他们刚刚
got married. Congratulations, and thanks, everybody, for your support. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi Oregon, or on Instagram and write it too. But our true home on the internet is 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
结婚了。恭喜你们，也感谢大家的支持。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99pi，或者在Instagram上关注。但我们在互联网上真正的家是99pi.org。Radio Topia。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。